being a friend Super Fan is the worst
personality
tra friend is
excellent that's a best Personality yeah
we did that we did that whole trivia
night no everybody loves friends here
well you don't really know friends as
much you're just trying to argue I am I
don't I don't really know friends I have
no
friends I don't really know you know who
an amazing who knows everything about
friends Yos Lanos he's seen every
episode every episode you can quiz him
Yos lanthum who made killing of a sacred
deer and dog Tu and dog Tu is obsessed
with friends is obsessed with friends
it's true it's the most like adorable
mindblowing it is it's adorable it's